what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so now that we're getting back into
the swing of things of our regularly
scheduled programming and this one we
continue our discussion on the return of
Bruce Wayne now remember the whole
premise of Dark Knight's metal is that
it's really rooted in Final Crisis right
like we talked about that with regards
to the main Final Crisis event and to
the first video that we did on the
return of Bruce Wayne in the sense that
in Final Crisis Bruce Wayne was
basically time-displaced he was thrown
all the way back to the very early days
of man but what he began doing was
basically scribbling all these different
drawings these symbols of the Justice
League of Superman Wonder Woman cyborg
and Batman himself the result is that he
basically inspired the creation of a new
tribe known as the bat rod now again
that matters because if you've been
reading Dark Knight's metal what we know
is that somewhere along the line in
humanity's history there arose the bat
rod this basically says it's all because
of Bruce Wayne at the same time Bruce
being timed his place being thrown all
the way back to the early days of
humanity got the attention of Barbados
in the dark multiverse and that's what
inspired Barbados to basically realize
the positive multiverse was there and
attempt to find a way to invade it so
what this does is just continue this
story of the return of Bruce Wayne and
as we go through this you'll see little
moments here and there where we'll
basically kind of hint back to the
events of Dark Knight's metal head back
to the idea of Barbados we basically had
Batman fighting against this giant
tentacle monster and trying to defeat it
as best he could now this monster is
actually a concept it actually has a
name in order to avoid spoilers we'll
talk about what that purpose is later
but for right now it is a pretty cool
concept but one of the things that you
notice is that it's basically chasing
Bruce Wayne throughout the timestream
because where the where the first video
had him in the early days of humanity
this video right now has them in the old
colonial days specifically in the early
days of Gotham City and it's pretty cool
because what we end up doing here is
having him basically just picked up by
some woman who's just kind of out there
in the woods somewhere she nurses him
back to health and that kind of thing
but remember when it comes to understand
when he was time displaced for the most
part his memories are gone he doesn't
really remember anything about who he
was he basically was sent back to the
early days of man as a fresh slate with
these little bits of memories here and
there little indications like Justice
League different things like that and so
he was able to maintain some measure of
his identity but from here what we
actually do is jump to a place called
the van
now the vanishing points that actually
you know a really really interesting
concept because to the best of my
understanding the vanishing point more
or less kind of exists like this idea
that every universe has its own
vanishing point I'm not 100% sure about
that so if you're somebody who's very
familiar with it feel free to try them
down in the comment section so I can add
that little tidbit of knowledge time
mental database of DC Comics with Bruce
Wayne being thrown back into the past
this effectively initiated a sort of
hunt of sorts with like Superman and the
Green Lantern and rip hunter a well
known time traveler and DC Comics as
well as Booster Gold to basically find
Bruce Wayne and to bring him back now
one of the things that I hope you guys
also notice here is that Superman and
Green Lantern are really kind of the
heavy hitters and this particular bit of
a story but with Booster Gold and with
rip hunter they're very familiar with
the timestream and so they basically
grabbed Time Traveller's to go with them
and help them navigate the waters them
arriving at the vanishing point the long
and short is that this is basically
where all things coalesce the indication
is that you have the very beginnings of
the universe or even the multiverse if
you want to go that far back but no
matter what happens all these different
universes that spawn you know they're
just kind of coming to existence by any
manner of any particular situation they
all basically coalesce down into a
singular point and that center point is
the end of all things that collapse of
the multiverse so to speak the vanishing
point basically exists in the moments
before the multiverse collapses and the
whole idea is that the vanishing point
basically allows people allows these
sort of timekeepers to essentially stand
at the end of all things and to
basically just categorize and quantify
and essentially make a giant time
capsule in the sense that they basically
document and they record everything
that's ever happened throughout the time
stream so that when everything comes to
an end and it's reborn memories of the
previous universe will be kept on it'll
be you know given to the next generation
or something along those lines and so
what we end up having is this sort of
biological / you know technological
device basically this being that kind of
exists at the end of this time stream
but is essentially telling you know
these guys who are here the person
you're looking for Bruce Wayne is time
displace he's out here in this exact
location but it's kind of cool because
it's basically sort of Grant Morrison
giving us this perception of all these
different things that exist out there
basically every single moment in time
and it's all really interesting because
Superman points out that finding Batman
is going to be a lot harder than they
thought it would be because of
one of these you know spheres basically
represents a singular moment than what
they have to do is literally go through
every single one of these moments and
try to find Batman the problem is that
it's not that simple because basically
the entire collapse of the multiverse is
happening in like nine and a half
minutes so basically they don't have
enough time to try to find Bruce now the
cool thing about this is jumping back to
the modern day what we end up having is
Bruce Wayne basically adopting the
moniker of Mordechai when it comes to
Bruce his instincts as a detective are
really kind of embedded into who he is
and that's one of the things that more
some hints on here it's been such an
ingrained part of his life it's who he
is being a detective is like eating or
sleeping or drinking it's just a
fundamental nature of what makes him who
he is and so the cool thing is that what
he ends up doing is investigating this
bat it's basically been pinned to a door
and again that's the nature of this
because of the fact that the bat tribe
had risen to prominence because the bat
rod kind of signified the devil based on
different religious groups that's how
things are view here and colony hill you
know it's basically this idea that bats
kind of signify the devil that bats
signify evil different things on those
lines and there's a long history of that
even here in the real world you know the
history of bats in terms of how people
view them the bad omens they represent
different things along those lines so
again there's a lot of Grant Morrison
grabbing some real-world concepts and
throwing them in but basically Bruce
Wayne goes through you know under the
name of Mordecai he goes through and
basically does this huge investigation
about a missing man by the name of
Matthieu I think it is and the whole
idea is that he basically starts looking
at all these different clues coming to
the realization that a knitting needle
was used to basically you know stab
Matthew or at least you don't have blood
on it that the clothes of Matthew were
basically sewing up and they were kept
you know in pretty decent condition and
what he basically draws a conclusion of
is that Matthews wife killed him that
was basically what happened now in
response to this the local community
begins to freak out and all of it's done
under a guy named brother malleus
brother malleus is sort of an indication
or at least the closest thing we get to
a villain in this story but remember
Grant Morrison's grabbing a lot of real
world themes doctor in the days of the
Salem witch trial it was basically this
idea that if people didn't understand
what was going on with regards to how
the world worked and people in it they
were just charted up to witchcraft this
person does a thing I don't really
understand they look different or they
talk different or whatever the case may
be they're not like the rest of us
they're not like us Christians therefore
they're witches and so that was a huge
thing
all over the place the idea of malleus
he essentially goes through and finds
people who are witches now again this is
all really kind of nonsense I mean the
fact that this woman would grab a bat
she would hit it to church door the
argument is that she's a witch now we're
not explicitly told why she's just being
charged with witchcraft and so the
result is that ruse basically sort of
leaves and what he ends up doing is
picking back up with this girl named
Annie it gives us a little bit of
information about what's going on here
the fact that brother malleus is
basically just a witch finder but
there's still a lot of information about
what's going on with the character of
Annie it really kind of flushes her out
in this sense that she seems to be a
legitimate witch who really ascribes to
like nature different things like that
says I don't really believe in the
judeo-christian God for me is the gods
of nature different things along those
lines but the indication here regardless
of the circumstances is that in his mind
she's more of an outlier she's more of
an outcast and that creates kind of a
bond between the two of them because
while he's operating under the name
Mordecai he still doesn't really
remember anything about himself and so
in a lot of ways he views himself as an
outcast so it creates a bit of a bond
between these two people not for here we
basically pick up with the body of
Matthew which is essentially torn apart
more or less or at least at the very
least been burned but it's this idea
that Bruce Wayne is using his detective
skills instinctively to look at this
entire situation and to realize there's
basically something going on here
there's a bigger picture taking place
here than what these guys believe with
the character of malleus you know he
basically starts making all these
different claims and talking about
things like an eclipse and so on and so
forth and it starts to sort of ring some
bells in the mind of Bruce Wayne he gets
these little glimpses from the first
book that we talked about this big
Eclipse different things like that just
small little moments here and there not
enough to put the pieces together but
enough to create some measure of
understanding about what's going on so
what he is up doing is immediately
traveling back to Annie and demanding to
know what his story is
and what Annie basically says is that as
far as she knows he just rose out of the
water one day she doesn't know where he
came from she has no idea who he is or
what he's about but in her mind because
of the fact that the town is filled with
people who are so humorous who are so
arrogant who are so full of the idea
that they are Christian and right
because God told them so is basically
this notion that she considers them to
be the downtrodden
failure in society in her mind their
desire to pull out witches here and
there is basically going on a crusade to
destroy things they don't understand but
in her mind she's
basically making this case at a time
will come when they will most likely
destroy themselves whatever the case may
be and she's just sort of waiting until
it happens but what she also says is she
had basically prayed to her own gods and
she had summoned a beast that she
thought would be capable of taking out
all these arrogant people and so what we
end up finding out is that this monster
that essentially shows up on the scene
is the same one that's been tracking
Bruce Wayne so it's interesting because
with Amy traveling back to her home she
ends up finding it rated by brother
malleus and all his various forces and
it's essentially this idea that she's
just guilty of witchcraft they throw her
on trial they immediately find her
guilty and they basically throw her into
the fire pit and that's about it
and so while Bruce Wayne tries to take
out here are these tentacles and tries
to destroy this monster at the same time
it's also a bit of recognition looking
around this kid if he begins to realize
this cave is familiar the indication is
that this is the Batcave this is Gotham
City before it becomes Gotham City and
it's interesting because in this moment
what we do is we jump back to the to the
vanishing point and we pick up with you
know Superman and Green Lantern and rip
hunter and you know Booster Gold and we
end up finding out that this construct
they've been talking to you is actually
Bruce Wayne at the end of time and what
he says is that he's on a mission to
essentially quote-unquote fix things
very cloak-and-dagger were not given a
lot of information here but what
Superman says is that Batman's basically
been turned into a booby trap when
Darkseid hit him with the Omega sanction
and sent him back to the beginning of
time where he was supposed to have died
instead what's happening here is that
Darkseid since something else after
Bruce Wayne and relied on his detective
instincts and so what this means is that
Darkseid not only time displace Bruce
Wayne he said whatever this monster is
after Bruce
hoping that Bruce the detective skills
would kick in and he would just start
time hopping the result is that he would
end up in the modern day and effectively
activate whatever trap it was that
Darkseid had set up and so again it's
interesting because a lot of this stuff
is very ambiguous there's a lot of clues
here but we're not really given any
definitive answers to things not only
that what we also end up finding out is
that this man brother malleus is
actually a guy named Nathaniel Wayne the
first member of the Wayne family to take
up residence in Gotham City and that's
what's so crazy about this because what
Grant Morrison says is that where
previously we just kind of left to left
to our own devices left to believe that
the Wayne family was honorable
they did great things and truth they're
rooted in ignorance they're rooted in
bias cruelty and this was so crazy about
this is because it basically says that's
the nature of the Wayans the Wayans are
people who just do terrible things over
the course of their existence and it
wasn't until society got a little bit
smarter and got a little bit wiser that
they did the same thing and so what we
end up doing here is finding out that
with any more or less being eliminated
due to the claims of witchcraft
where Bruce is essentially
time-displaced yet again Gotham City
began to grow Gotham City began to
expand and it turned into the town that
we've become most familiar with leading
up to the modern day and so the way the
story ends is with Bruce basically
rising out of the ocean just like he did
you know when he first met Annie riding
out arising out of a lake only for him
to have a boot strapped to her boot push
to his head and then for us to find out
he's in the era of the Pirates not only
that he's basically being gang pressed
on to the crew of Blackbeard would that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]